[Music]
getting trust in science is going to be
one of the big challenges going forward
trust takes time to build in a moment to
lose
and it is worth fighting for
but this cannot happen in a vacuum it
needs to be a conversation with a lot of
different actors of civil societies and
this is i think what we're doing in
berlin
[Music]
we're not
talking within a closed environment
interdisciplinary collaborations are the
key
aligning with communication listening to
one another is also essential
only if
people
show solidarity work together cooperate
scientists the economy politicians can
we really tackle the big challenges of
our times
science is something very abstract for
many people but once you make it
experienceable you create a connection
to what this knowledge actually means
and why we do it
so it does expose you to
people from all over the world with
different cultures different approaches
in a celebration of what science can do
for humanity
[Music]
you